hi my name is Daria Smitha I am the
Zoroastrian representative to the
chaplains board at MIT and Harvard here
and a little bit about myself I am a
research scientist I have a background
in electrical engineering and I've
specialized in biomedical engineering
and especially in a clinical area I work
with patients and we do research in
investigating the various disorders that
happen in speech and voice in the clinic
I'm also in my role as a chaplain I have
the privilege of representing the
Zoroastrian faith and interacting with
students as well as the community at
large in the Boston area we have a very
vibrant community I would say about 250
or so so you know dozens of families are
pulled from the Massachusetts
Connecticut Rhode Island areas in terms
of colleges since we are on the smaller
scale of faith communities our students
are they get together not just from
Harvard what we bring together at
Northeastern Tufts Brandeis MIT to put
together events and ever since I was a
graduate student here at Harvard n MIT
we put together events that brought
panel discussions of leaders and
scholars in the Zoroastrian faith to
tell us about about Zoroastrianism as
well as some groundwork doing some
service projects helping do some farming
getting our hands dirty so this this
opportunity to be on the board at
Harvard has given me the kind of
privilege and opportunity to have access
to students and hopefully we create a
forum for dialogue not just within the
faith and Zoroastrian faith but also
really pushing at multi-faith and
interfaith engagement and learning about
more than just who we are in terms of
questions that I get and who comes in
the door or who shoots me an email I
would say one of
primary role for me is to make the
student comfortable in this very vibrant
dynamic maybe fast-paced setting
especially if they're coming from
another country if they're coming from
Pakistan or India the Austrian of faith
has many communities abroad and when
they come here it's not just being that
faith-based person to help in terms of
the spiritual guidance but it's really
to help find housing to find a community
here that's makes them feel comfortable
and when they come we try to have them
meet not just other students but let
them know that there are families nearby
and they've really become a part of that
that fabric that very community-based
connection so that's one big role I get
a lot of emails from families abroad
that say my son my daughter is coming to
Harvard and would you help and that's my
that's where I'm glad just have that
opportunity to serve them and and help
make them feel comfortable